علمنا هذا الصباح أن novovax قد
بدأت المرحلة الثالثة من التجارب
السريرية للقاح covid19 في الولايات المتحدة
وانضمت إليزابيث كوهين كبير المراسلين الطبيين في المكسيك الآن
إليزابيث ، ما الذي نعرفه أكثر عن
هذا اللقاح وتجربته
أنت تعرف أن هذا اللقاح قليل
يختلف قليلاً عن المستشار الحديث ، لكن من المثير
جدًا أن تدخل شركة خامسة المرحلة
الثالثة في تجربة إكلينيكية واسعة النطاق ، فهذه
هي المرحلة الأخيرة
قبل أن تقوم إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير بمراجعتها ومعرفة ما إذا
كان يجب
إعطاؤها للأشخاص في جميع أنحاء البلاد ، لذلك دعونا
نأخذ  نظرة على ما نعرفه عن
novavax حول هذه
التجربة السريرية ، يصل عدد الأشخاص إلى 30000 شخص في
سن 18 وما فوق ، وهذا هو مدى حجم التجربة
25 من المشاركين فيها ، ويأملون أن
يكونوا قد خططوا ليكونوا في سن
65 وما فوق ، وهذا أمر مهم لأن هؤلاء
هم الأشخاص الذين لسوء الحظ لديهم
بعض ردود الفعل الأسوأ على
الطمع 19.
15 بالمائة سيكونون من السود أو الأمريكيين الأفارقة.
10 إلى 20 بالمائة سيكونون من أصل لاتيني  وواحد
إلى اثنين في المائة من
الأمريكيين الهنود ، وهذا ما
نعرفه حتى الآن
حول ما سيحدث ،
ستكون المرحلة الثالثة من التجربة
حيث سيحصلون على جرعتين بعد
ثلاثة أسابيع
الآن ، دعونا نلقي نظرة على مكان حدوث ذلك
نوعًا ما بالمقارنة
مع الأنواع الأخرى ، نوع من تاريخ
الأشياء هنا ، pfizer و moderna
، لقد تم بالفعل ترخيصهم من قبل
FDA astrazeneca ، بدأت تجربتهم في المرحلة 3 في 31 أغسطس ، بدأت تجربة جونسون وجونسون في المرحلة 3 في
23 سبتمبر
ونوفافاكس كما نعلم  بدأت تجاربهم في المرحلة الثالثة
اليوم ،
سانوفي ، وهم في المرحلة الأولى والثانية ، لذا
فهذه قائمة بالأشخاص الذين حصلوا على
تمويل سريع للعملية ،
وبعبارة أخرى ، فإن
تمويل
الحكومة الفيدرالية لإجراء هذه التجارب شديدة الأهمية
مكلف لعمل بيانا
ومن المثير للإعجاب فقط أن نرى مدى
سرعة حدوث كل هذا بسرعة كبيرة
جدًا آه كيف يمكن
مقارنة نوفوفاكس باللقاحين الطبيين
والفيزا  المتوفر حاليًا
في الولايات المتحدة ،
كما تعلم ، إنه مختلف تمامًا ،
سأصبح أكثر جرأة هنا عليك
أكثر من ذلك بقليل ،
لذا لكي تعمل هذه اللقاحات بشكل جيد ،
حتى تعمل هذه اللقاحات بشكل
أساسي ما لديها  يحدث
هو أن الجهاز المناعي يجب أن يرى جزءًا
من الفيروس ويقول يا إلهي إنني أتعرض
للهجوم
ومن ثم يتعلم كيفية الاستجابة ولكن
نظرًا لأنه جزء فقط من الفيروس ،
فإنه ليس تهديدًا كبيرًا ولكنه يتعلم
كيفية  استجب حتى إذا
تعرضت للتهديد من قبل فيروس حقيقي ، فإن جهاز المناعة الخاص بك
يقول إنني أتذكر هذا ،
وأعلم أن ما يجب فعله ما فعلته شركة Pfizer و
Moderna هو أنهم يعطون
اللقاح الخاص بهم يعطي تعليمات
حول كيفية جعل هذا جزءًا من
الفيروس  مجرد التعليمات
التي تقوم بها novovx هي أنها ترسل جزءًا فعليًا
من الفيروس جزءًا من الفيروس
الذي صنعوه ،
لذا فهم نوعًا ما يصنعون هذا الجزء المزيف
من الفيروس ويرسلون الجزء الفعلي
في المرحلة الفيزيائية الثالثة من التجارب السريرية
تخبرنا  أن نهجي Moderna و pfizer
يعمل ، يجب أن نرى في هذا الأمر